tendencies yeah with three sections yeah
and um
and dreaming as well i mean i talk about
uh giving saving and spending at the end
of the book and why we do all those but
the savings i attach to dreams because
if you're not saving you're probably not
dreaming because you have nothing that
you're saving for and so
dreaming and you're not saving you are
really just a dreamer yeah that's right
right right instead of it going into
goals and all of that that's right yeah
so um yeah it's been yeah it's been
really fun it's been a fun money book
and that's been a crazy week
yes i mean you you were on good morning
america and then the next day the uh
hours hours later yeah you got you
barely got that in because you would
have got
you you wouldn't have made it they would
have nixed your interview if it had
happened before good morning
washington d.c coverage and you've
gotten nixed on a bunch of them later on
yeah but um yeah used to call that
getting oj'd oj was on trial during my
first
book book tour that's how long ago i did
a book tour the first time
and uh anytime he would go the bathroom
they would stop all network everything
and
follow him to the bathroom i remember i
mean i was little during all of them
aging myself or showing my youth
but full house would get paused on like
tgif and stuff going to teach i have
back in the day and then
cameron couldn't do anything in full
house all that yeah they paused all my
shows and
i was like tant oj but but the book's
been fun so thanks for thanks for
supporting it and pushing it out because
it's fun to help people and think
through
why you handle money the way you do not
just the how-to yeah so proud of you
guys it's been a great run
and uh it's been a good week with the
reset event
and you can still probably get that i
think at daveramsey.com go over there
and look and the reset 2021 event
for sure there's a bundle running on uh
ramsey plus
and uh you crashed the servers yeah we
did that
yeah we did we broke the internet and
then we came home and fixed it because i
don't like breaking the internet that's
not good
um so not good at all but anyway yeah
it's uh
uh ramsay plus you can go there and get
a a free trial right now and there's a
new thing they put in there that's
really important
because it has to do with managing
behaviors and your book of course is all
about behaviors
is this idea that that during the first
90 days there's a day-by-day
week-by-week step-by-step thing to do
and i'm talking about the baby steps
they're in there too we got a baby steps
tracker in there and all that but they
if you're in ramsey plus they're going
to hold your hand
and say go do this then do this then do
this that's the thing get it done
get it out there and and that's what you
do which is really important because
when you're if you are
you know new to the show or you're just
kind of starting the process of thinking
okay i want to control my money it can
be very overwhelming
because you're thinking about insurance
and taxes and mortgages and real estate
and refinancing and emergency fund and
debt i mean like there's
where do you start it's just this like
huge bubble so the baby steps for sure
give you those big seven steps to do
but to have someone walk you through on
a day-to-day basis it's so it really is
helpful it's helpful
to have your hand held through
especially those beginning stages
so you can kind of get your your
foundation laid absolutely so you can
pick up know yourself know your money at
rachelcrews.com or daveramsey.com or
anywhere great books are sold amazon all
that
and uh it's here it's official it's 20
and it is officially a national
bestseller
and very very very proud of that very
proud of you very well done thank you
you guys uh you and the team have worked
very hard on the team
unbelievable number of hours to get to
where we are today and um
to pull this off and especially i mean
doing a book tour during a coveted
pandemic is just
weird i mean we had to do all kinds of
wacky virtual this and
natural that and huh so we had fun with
it though you did have fun with you did
a
virtual book signing and it was really
fun we all had champagne
streamers we had music you were in the
room by yourself drinking champagne with
a camera
zoom all 300 people every night we all
just hung out it was great
i love it ah this is the dave ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
casey is in seattle hi casey welcome to
the dave ramsey show how can rachel and
i help
hi dave and rachel's awesome to get a
talk with you guys you too
i'm an 18 year old in my first year of
college studying mechanical engineering
at an inn state university
i was offered many scholarships and the
university ended up paying me to attend
their school
love it um i yeah i've been working
since i was 15 i have about 25 000
in a savings account and my dad has
another 15
another 25 000 invested in a 529 in a
custodial account
i don't know if i should start investing
myself or just keep this save this 20 my
own money saved and what's the plan with
this with that
it's awesome awesome casey way to go
what an incredible job
yeah if i were you casey i would just
hold on to that 25 000
and get through college because you
never know what can happen
bumps in the road you want to make sure
that you are staying debt free through
this process
and once you graduate college then you
can say okay what do i want to do with
this money do i want to
use it to help with moving expenses
because maybe you move to a new city
is it for a down payment on a home are
you going to invest it because you're
going to rent for a little bit
you can kind of decide what to do with
it there but i would keep it liquid
meaning you can get to it quickly if you
need it through
college just to ensure that you're going
you're going to get
through debt free but the fact that
they're paying you for college casey
i was jealous of those people i had one
friend and she went and got a check
every semester and i was like oh my gosh
it's so great it's awesome it's just
amazing well done so here's the thing
obviously you're going to take the free
money first
we're going to use your dad's 529 second
the last money we're going to use is
your money because the 529
has to be used for higher education or
gets taxed
yeah your money doesn't your money's
just sitting there
so i hope that you clear college
with uh all of your money and maybe even
some of the 529 money
and the rest of it they pay you and you
get scholarships and everything all the
way through you've been
very very bright well done but the 529
can be passed
it can be passed to another to a sibling
not a ch not generationally
not generationally yeah you can your dad
can use it for your brother or sister
or you can he can he can uh he can use
it for his college or his wife's college
but her kids can it go down three
generations two generations i think it
can i think it can now so casey you
might be able which i know you're not
thinking about children right now
but if you held on to that 529 plan
there's a chance that when you have kids
you can use that money for them
yeah if you don't end up spending any of
it
yours or the 529 and you get the
scholarship paid gig all the way through
you are amazing number one but number
two uh
uh yeah we'll figure out something you
can figure out something to do with that
529 either siblings or
kids or somebody without having to just
cash it out and get hammered on the
taxes
so uh but but the good it is not a bad
thing
the investment we're making right now is
in casey
you're a better investment than a mutual
fund is studying mechanical engineering
i mean you're going to be amazing
so you're just wow what a great what a
great story
and you get that and i just want to like
i want to bottle
that in like a little mister and so when
someone walks up and says you have to
have a steady name they got a college i
just want to spray them
just spray a little casey on it oh my
gosh right in her little face just
right in her little face well and props
to her though
but she did it all because up here well
she's smart and she's getting those
scholarships even though
she was wise but i don't know we don't
know that she's necessarily a savant
i mean she just was wise and
hard-working no that's not taking
anything away from her but those of you
that are not getting full rides to
college for academics you can
still pick a school that you can afford
you can still work
you can still apply for other
scholarships and all that which she did
all of
yes pick the school she could afford
in-state intuition just amazing
very well done it's almost like she read
anthony o'neil's book debt-free degree
joe is in topeka kansas hi joe how are
you
hey dave and rachel how are you guys
great how can we help
hey so we ran into an issue as of
yesterday um we're on baby steps four
five and six
we currently just refinanced our house
to a fifteen year fixed
um turns out we thought a little leak in
our basement we got inspected turns out
that the the
whole basement is actually kind of
falling apart on us it's bowing
it has cracks and then there's black
mold on the other side of the wall
it's uh the project's a lot bigger than
our emergency fund
and we're kind of in that like emotional
stage where you're like i don't want to
make an extreme decision
so i thought this would be my first time
calling you and it's a good one i think
yeah that is a good one okay so what's
your household income
uh we make about 80 000 a year how much
is in the emergency fund
uh we have ten thousand and what is the
bid on the wall
uh well i've got two so far one's
eighteen thousand and one
nineteen thousand and i have one more
coming uh this coming week
okay cool all right well um
the bad news is you've got a messed up
situation and uh it's real that
that wall that mold has to go away and
you don't want this wall to fall in
because it's bowing
it's got hydrostatic pressure it's got
water on the other side of it i've been
in that situation
many times with properties that we were
rehabbing or owned or bought at
foreclosure
and then you walk in and go oh crap the
basement's about to fall in so
um and the bids you gave me don't sound
ridiculously uh out of line or anything
and they're close to each other which
tells you that nobody's in there trying
to gig you right
so we've got pretty good pretty good
contractors on the scene it sounds like
you've got half the money now and so how
fast can you get nine thousand dollars
together it's not going to fall in
tomorrow
yes sir um i it would probably take a
few months
um just you know standard expenses and
if you just
stop your 401k temporarily and you say
house is on fire we have a major mess on
the hands
and we need to save four thousand
dollars a month for two months
you could do it yes sir and and really
that's what
we could need yeah and so what you do is
just schedule your schedule your
contractor
that way okay if this is a uh a
two-month
job he can start now
yes sir um i have a quick question we
have about thirty four thousand dollars
in equity in our house
uh would it be worth uh using that
nope no not gonna tell you to borrow
money awesome
never have i'm not gonna start with this
space
yeah no it's uh i didn't know if that
counted as our income or not
as a savings or anything no it's not
savings because you're borrowing money
you're talking about borrowing money on
your equity right
yeah yes i suppose so yes sir well it is
i mean it's a debt
try not paying it they'll foreclose on
you so you're going into debt so you're
taking a home equity loan or whatever
some kind of second mortgage there to do
this and absolutely not so if it's a
two-month project which it
probably is close to that you can go
ahead and start you've got the you've
got more than half of the money and
you'll have the other half while the
project is underway
and but the contractor doesn't get all
of his money up front and he shouldn't
anyway that's bad business
yes sir okay so you whenever you feel
like you can
stage your cash with the complete you'll
have all the money with the completion
of the job
if you need to wait a month to start it
it's probably okay
i mean it's not your family wasn't dying
of mold yesterday
uh or day before yesterday then
yesterday you found all of it so
i'm not suggesting you live in mold
infested houses for the rest of your
life i'm the
new rooms he's crazy he's lost his ever
loving mind no it's not what i'm saying
but i'm saying that you know a roof that
is leaking
uh you can stop the leak temporarily
until you get the money for the
fix and you know there's this stuff is
most of these things they're like you
said
joe said it well it's emotional yeah
it's oh crap
i was just getting things rolling and
the stupid basement fell in ah
you know and it's emotional it's
disgusting well that's the part of money
that can be frustrating as you're
working a plan
and you're going down and checking off
these baby steps having to go back to
baby step three now
pausing and saving back up the emergency
fund it takes a toll on you i mean it's
not fun it's not fun to go backwards but
that's life and that's why it's here yep
so you'd rather have 10 grand
sitting there in cash that you have to
use versus having no money
so it is but it can be discouraging to
go back but it's worth it it's worth
continuing on
and saying okay we're back a little bit
but we're gonna continue i mean the good
news is it wasn't
forty eight thousand dollars and you
make forty thousand
and you're broke yeah uh right you know
but if it's to a point this is reachable
this is doable
yes so for cars there's kind of that
whole thing okay i'm driving a beater
when do i
upgrade when is the repairs too much to
go into the car right like that whole
discussion
but for a house that's hard no house you
got to fix it you can't sell it right
right because the buyer can't the buyer
can't get a permanent mortgage on it if
the basement's falling exactly
so you're fixing this house or you're
going to give it away
you know you're going to sell it for 70
cents on the dollar or something because
you know sell it a yeah forty thousand
dollar discount for an eighteen thousand
dollar repair or something like that
right that'll happen too
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet
the needs of your growing family or
small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
thanks for joining us america i'm dave
ramsey rachel cruz ramsey personality
four-time national bestseller boom boom
is my co-host also my daughter a little
bit proud today
know yourself know your money came in at
number two in the national bestseller
list this week on its first week out
very well done thank you america for
your support on this
and uh we know you're enjoying the book
we see all the posts on instagram and
everywhere else and
we're glad to know yourself know your
money is a blessing matt is with us
matt's in
ames iowa hi matt how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up awesome
uh thanks for taking my call i've i've
been a listener since i was about
uh big enough to ride with my dad in the
combine so i was probably one of your
earliest am radio listeners
i love it i'm going today i'm calling
today i've got a question
i'm a student that's going to be
graduating in may i've got a job lined
up
in the omaha area and i'm looking for
places to rent
i've got a girlfriend soon to be fiance
hopefully she doesn't hear this
recording that she'll also be graduating
but she won't be graduating until
a little bit later in august and so i
know you recommend spending about 25
of your take home on housing and so i'm
serious whether or not i should take her
future income into consideration when
i'm looking even though
she won't be moving in probably for four
to six months after
i start living there you can make it
that long
yeah i don't care i mean in other words
if it's if it's a larger percentage
of your income without her income
joining the household you can make it
the the point of the 25 percent mat is
just to not be house poor for the next
five years
you're struggling long because all your
money is going to housing and you don't
need money for a car you don't have any
money for
uh anything else emergencies or anything
else but for four months and
in a transitionary period uh between
you moving in and getting engaged and
getting married that's a
that's okay for four months you think
rach yeah absolutely i was going to say
yeah after you guys get married decide
to move in
and that's when i would factor it in um
like if it's coming up but
yeah like he's saying i wouldn't do two
years of that necessarily but a few
months here or there during transitions
totally fine so if you know her income
and your income
you could take on 25 of that and it
might be 40
of yours for just a few months you're
kind of holding your breath as long as
it doesn't keep you from paying for the
wedding or something like that cause you
to go into debt
that's fine and uh for a short period of
time so you could tell you can do the
calculation based on the joined income
as long as you can float it for that
four months without debt does that make
sense
yeah absolutely thank you yeah this is a
long-term
equation you can do a lot of stuff on
the short term to survive
but the long-term equation is don't be
in a house where you can't breathe
because then you'll go into debt for
every little thing
that comes along that's what's going to
happen and matt i'll just reiterate this
you said
she won't be moving in for a few months
because of august
but you guys are not engaged yet so
think about the wedding planning
i would not recommend living together
until you're married
and so if the wedding is in between
those times those four months like if
you're about to be engaged
you guys are going to plan to get
married soon after she graduates yeah i
kind of heard four months after he moves
in in august is what i heard
he thinks you're gonna get married like
by christmas that's that's what i read
into it but i might be wrong
so you're right yeah well i was gonna
just say okay there's a wedding in
between two remember that because that's
an expense too yeah that's that's the
big deal yeah
don't don't let that sneak up on you
good point mason is with us in
tucson arizona hi mason welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hello sir thanks for having me today
sure man what's up
um so i am
you're cutting out brother you're going
to speak directly into your phone we
lost
can you hear me now yes sir good okay so
i'm
i'm new to the whole dave ramsey saving
your money
i thought i knew how to budget turned
out i didn't
so december 26 i bought your book
total money makeover a couple days later
i bought everyday millionaire by chris
hogan wow
then january 6
10 days after that i sold my truck to
get rid of
12 000 in debt that i had wow
now so my student loans
are twenty eight thousand five hundred
and fifty two
uh my net my net income is forty three
thousand
um eight hundred and eighty six uh
monthly
expenses are about 1800 to 1900
so my question is i have a wedding
coming up in august
i have 10 000 in savings right now
do i put some of the money and savings
into the student loan debt or do i hold
on to it
for future wedding expenses
i would figure out what my wedding
expenses and hold that much back and
throw the rest of it towards the student
loan
do you have a wedding budget yet
um we do like it so we're paying for a
good
majority and then our parents are paying
for some
too uh pretty much everything is done
we just have to get like you know
settled with uh the bartender the
photographer
you know little stuff like that good
good which are pricier items though
mason photographer and bartender so
yeah just figuring out how much you guys
have left to spend
um so whatever that amount is yes then
you can take some of that 10 000 use it
for that
save keep that thousand dollars your
baby emergency fund and then everything
else you can throw out the student loan
so if you were gonna guess what is your
part left to pay on the wedding
just off the top of your head off the
top of my head
probably with bartenders photographers
probably around five thousand i'd say
okay we'll use that as an example what
you what i want you to do i want you to
dig into it and make that number solid
because i don't want you to come up
short
okay okay so if it's 5 462 set 5 500
aside okay
so just go ahead and dial it in get it
dialed into the penny like you did on
the other stuff you've done a really
good job you jumped on this man
you jumped on it hard and uh that that
gives me a lot of hope for you guys that
there is listen there is nothing like a
quick start a quick start will get you
moving
and that's what you've done i'm proud of
you so get that dialed in
set that money aside don't touch it
that's the wedding it's already spent
you just hadn't given it to him yet
okay and you won't have you don't have
to worry about that it's over
then you set one thousand dollars aside
in another account as your little
starter baby step one
emergency fund and then as rachel said
you're just going to take the rest of it
and throw it at the student loans and
now everything out of your budget
boom boom boom we're going to smack the
crud out of those student loans between
now
and marriage and you know what you're
going to be well on your way on that by
the time you get there because
if you throw four or five grand at those
things now and then you've got a couple
grand a month to throw at them
between now and then you're gonna be
popping them
okay okay you're doing good yeah does
your does your fiance have
a lot of debt mason when you guys get
married she has no debt
awesome amazing yeah and then you're
going to combine your incomes when you
guys get married
as well so i mean like you'll yeah yeah
so how thrilled is she
and her dad that you're doing this
uh she's excited she's really excited
she i mean
she made comments about how you know i
was spending too much and stuff like
that and i
i didn't realize it until yeah i
sat down and actually looked at
everything where everything was going
and then
it just opened my mind so no she she
awesome very good well listen we're
going to give you a wedding gift i want
you to the two of you to be in ramsey
plus
for a year free as our gift as our
wedding gift and that includes financial
peace university it includes every
dollar the premium version
includes the baby step app and right now
it's got a quick 90-day start which is
the game plan you are on baby you are a
quick start dude
and uh there is uh no one regrets
getting a quick start
ever oh well the progress automatically
and it's like oh it just feels it's
it's great that's powerful powerful well
done so
hold on zach will pick up mason and
we'll get you signed up for ramsey plus
for a year you and the fiance
and you guys can start tracking with
each other and that'll that'll
take all the stuff you're doing and
really really dial it in it's
the detailed plan to show you exactly
what to do and how to do it and
you're really cooking man you're doing
really good i'm so proud of you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from augustus
in kentucky my wife struggles at keeping
our grocery budgets
and i don't know how to help her looking
at every dollar in our food budget
including out to eat and groceries
is about an eighth of our total budget
is that enough for two adults with no
kids
is it too much do you have any tips on
deciding what is the right
what the right amount should be how can
i help support her so we can stick to
our budgets oh well august is welcome to
every problem
most american households have it's the
food budget
it does and like we struggle with this
too it's it's just i'm like one costco
run
can throw us over and i'm like oh my
gosh what like it's hard it really is
food is tough but two adults and no kids
uh and it's an eighth of our budget so
we say about 20 percent
can go to food 10 to 20 depending on
income and situation
um so yeah i mean
well yeah i'm i think you just look at
the amount
and say okay we can't do more than that
or more than this on this amount of
income
you know and you can use a percentage if
you want we have some recommended
percentages that are part of every
dollar
yeah part of the other that helps but um
most of let me if you've just started
this process
what i always tell people when i'm
teaching budgeting is whatever you think
you're spending on money
whatever you think you're spending on
food you're wrong you're spending more
and so in order to get the rest of the
budget to work
and everybody happy to work the rest of
the budget
go ahead and be up a little high on the
food budget you're not going to stay
high on the food budget for eight years
you'll quit eventually if every month
you hook up and there's a hundred
dollars left over
in your food budget or 200 left over in
your food budget eventually you'll dial
it down and go well our food budget is
really like 100 less i mean it's really
what it is
because you'll catch a rhythm and you'll
get to know what's going on
but uh i mean a thousand years ago when
the dinosaurs roamed the earth we
started to sit down and do our first
budget sharon and i you were a baby
and um i was all game on nerd on this
budget stuff i'm gonna we're gonna do
this we have envelope
with food written on it and you're not
getting any more money than this
and um i think we budgeted like 300
for food now this is 1980 something
right and so we budget
1990. we budget 300 for food well sharon
just
she's like this lady she's like you're
out of your mind you can't do it for
that we have four we have four family of
four three
you know two kids you can't do it for
that and i'm like well yeah you can i
mean just don't dispense with that gun
much
just get your butt out of the kroger you
know and we got this big argument
yes which you should have and you go
grocery shopping that's what i want him
to do and you know
that's exactly that's exactly what
happened ah she said we have to learn
that from y'all
she said all right genius you go do it
and i said well i will then
and i couldn't and i went over there and
i went
oh dead gum she's right yeah and so we
upped the food budget back in that day
to 500 a month that was a thousand years
ago it'd be
750 in today's dollars well with family
of five that's a lot
yeah but yeah that that was uh uh i mean
we but i was
man i was way off yeah and when i you
know so
yeah that's the thing i would tell you
probably
uh your wife's not the problem probably
you are like i was and probably you get
your butt
in the car go grocery shopping with her
and start to figure out what this stuff
costs and you might have some positive
some
suggestions yeah and if you guys are
depending on what baby step you're on to
i mean if you guys are baby steps
one two or three you want to be
realistic about what food costs but you
also don't have the leisure just to go
up and down every aisle and get whatever
you want like no no no i wasn't
suggesting no
i'm just saying for him though i'm
saying even basics you don't know what
they cost
right right but i'm saying to his wife
which
this is more me where i'm like oh yeah
i'm just gonna go see oh that sounds
good i'll just throw that
you know i can i can be a little bit
more like that now you can do that on
baby steps for and on
yeah you can enjoy it but if you're on
baby steps one through three then
she may say hey i'm gonna pull back on
some stuff and
i would lose the battle to the tune of a
couple of hundred dollars here
to win the war of getting on the same
page
with your spouse and getting on the same
page and running everything together
yes uh you know and everybody being
happy and you can always dial it back
down later
i mean very few unless unless your wife
is just a torp i mean
but very few mature people would say
week in and week out month in and month
out
oh i'm just going to hide this money to
the side we're
we've got more in this category than we
need no we we're going to admit that
we're high
right later and bring it back down
and we've done that in some categories
around our house
the other thing that i remember the
story i remember that um
is i've heard so many people say that
they felt the same way
when we say live like no one else so
later we can live and give like no one
else for sharon
she said someday and you're dreaming you
know we got the yellow pad out we're
trying to pay off the debts we're trying
to get the irs off our back we're
we're working and scratching and clawing
and she said
one of my big dreams is to have enough
money to just go to the grocery store
and fill the buggy with anything i want
and not worry about it
yes now that's a fairly low budget dream
at the end of the day but that was like
to not have to feel so constrained
worrying about every carton of eggs
we're looking at every every stinking
price on every generic
everything generic cheerios for god's
sakes and
um you know all the stuff and just to be
able to walk in
and buy whatever i want which now for
many many years she's been able to do
and she doesn't have to think about her
grocery budget anymore hasn't in a long
long time
but what what a great um goal to have
okay so something else i thought of
augustus if you're listening when i was
doing research on my book know yourself
know your money i was talking about
safety versus status and all that and
interviewing people with the safety
mindset
a lot of women said there's a comfort
of having a full fridge or a full pantry
yeah there's something emotional about
especially if they came from a home
where food was a struggle yes
so there there could be a safetyness
there
that she feels the need to have if she
doesn't have you know if she's not
cutting back
and she is buying a little bit more than
maybe you guys need necessarily there
could be
an emotional safety aspect of that and
so to kind of dig into that and look to
say okay are there other places that we
can have that security
and maybe save a little bit on the food
budget but it's amazing how many women
i talked to who said i if i have a full
fridge i feel like okay i'm good
yeah like it's yeah yeah there's
something about it there's an emotion
like an emergency fund
yeah there's an emotional thing to it
especially if you have kids and all that
well
it's a uh nesting thing you know just to
make sure that your family's fed
yes i know my family's fettle i know my
family's fed yeah and
uh just very very important so your food
budget
um will change a little
between baby steps one two three and
then later on you can relax it a little
bit in four five six
but it's not going to change a ton one
other thing you may find in your food
budget that you can do
is when we started out we had two
separate envelopes one for restaurants
and one for groceries so that we didn't
go to the restaurant and eat the grocery
money
because you can do that really easily oh
yeah and keep those categories separate
and if you're in one two and three
you shouldn't be in a restaurant anyway
you should be getting out of debt you
should be eating at home and cooking
from home and
uh you know saving the money and so but
but yeah
i think if you some of you guys i mean i
haven't done it in a long long time but
truth be told one of the biggest fights
we ever had back in the early days of
starting the stuff that we teach
was over that stinking food envelope and
she threw it at me
you go do it then genius and so i'm like
i will so i go over there
unstable money classroom years yeah i go
i go over there and i couldn't do it
and so then we went back together and i
watched really how good a job she was
doing
yeah to her credit and to my shame
because i had tried to shame her into
doing
you know and living on absolutely
nothing they wouldn't it wasn't possible
the numbers i was trying to make all the
numbers work and that was just one of
the categories
it was a problem you know but it didn't
uh man it your nerds you got to be
careful with this
whoever does the shopping if your
husband does the shopping you know
ladies you can't you can't
you got to go and get a little bit of
that in there that's right especially
when you're starting you don't have to
do it forever but it gets everybody in a
rhythm gets everybody on the same page
and that's just really
really important hey thanks for the
thanks for the question that's a good
one
that puts us out with the dave ramsey
show in the books thanks to james childs
our producer zach bennett filling in
today for
kelly daniel and i am dave ramsey your
host rachel cruz with me
we'll be back before you know it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where that is dumb cash is king the paid
off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author four times over her
new book know yourself know your money
just hit the wall street journal
bestseller list at number two
thank you america appreciate you backing
she's here with me to answer your
questions about life and money as well
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five jeff is in boston hi
jeff welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how's it going good man how can
i help
um uh so i just had some questions my
wife and i we've been doing the uh debt
relief program through you for about a
year and a half now
good we're still on the early baby steps
we have
um no car payments we have no credit
card debt anymore
and we are right now we own two homes
thank you right now we own two homes
um one is a single family home that we
don't live in we rent it out
it's on a small pond the next town over
it used to be my great grandfather's
house and i bought it from my mother
i owe about a hundred thousand dollars
on it and right now it's worth about
290.
um it does need some work and my wife
and i were talking about
possibly selling it and using some of
the money to pay off
she owes about deal about 50 000
of her school loans and possibly using
some of the proceeds to pay that off
and the house that we live in
is a multi-family home that we've been
renovating the upstairs apartment to get
it rented
and we are talking about turning our 30
by 40 garage
upstairs into a rental and property
income
too and possibly using some of the money
to do that
to get it going what's your household
income
we together make about two around 200
000
a year and how much debt have you got
left that's not real estate
uh we owe fifty thousand dollars in on
her school loans
that's all okay all right
yeah there is nothing wrong with your
plan
at all the only thing that gives me a
little bit of scratch
makes me want to scratch behind my ear a
little bit and go yeah
is it was grandpa's place and i don't
want you to look up five years from now
and go i shouldn't let that get away
well that's why i'm calling you are you
gonna have that feeling to sell it
i have that feeling now my wife wants to
sell it but i you know i feel like if
it's gonna need a septic system and
it doesn't need it right now it's
grandfathered in but i see about thirty
to forty thousand dollars right there
and what's the renovation take on the to
take your garage up to an apartment
the upstairs of the garage would
probably be about it doesn't have any
running water and plumbing so
talking like 10 grand for that and then
another 30 to 40
maybe 40 to 50 grand off together let's
call it 50 grand in student loans
50 grand over the garage and 50 grand on
grandpa's house
why don't we call it that and we say we
make 200.
yep i think in three years you've done
all three of these
and your your order of attack is student
loans are first
grandpa's house is next because it's uh
the septic's on this last leg
and then the build out over the garage
is in the third year
okay i think you keep them all and work
it out of cash flow because you make a
stinking boatload of money
yeah we do do pretty good uh this this
year's been tough we were really rarely
hitting all the uh the steps hard
until covert hit and we my wife and i
both have
not stopped working since it has
happened so we've been taking a real big
hit on child care
and stuff we have three kids yeah but
your income's up too
yes yeah no yes i i totally agree with
that yeah
and yeah so you're gonna have you're
gonna have some ebb and flow and all of
that but the bottom line is you're in
and you're out you guys have to make
have the ability to make a couple bills
right
yeah my wife's thing is is that i've put
i devoted a lot of time into doing a lot
of work at the
property that we own in the the lake
house
my great grandfather's house you know
i've built a big retaining wall over to
the driveway
and you need to stop inside you need to
stop
yeah and you need to work on work and
make money
because your wife's right and get
student loan cleared and then go get
grandpa's house done in one fell swoop
with a bunch of money
and get it over with and then it's no
longer it can't be a hobby house the
rest of your life if that's what it is
you got another problem
well that's what i don't want it to be
but to rent it out and get top dollar
for it no no no no i'm just trying to
rent it out right now because we're
going to get to it next year
and we're going to get it to top dollar
yeah it is rented out right now okay
then just shut up about it and rent it
don't fix anything else until you get
student loans paid and then fix
everything as fast as you can and then
build out the garage you see how i'm
doing this
yes and that's that's where i'm kind of
at but then i i felt like
selling it would make it happen a lot
faster
if it was gonna take you ten years i'd
tell you to sell it
yeah well but so my idea was if i sold
that place and then did the upstairs of
the garage then we would have two
incomes in
coming in from our house which we have
you mean we still have but
we would lose that in the long run in
the third yep
and you would lose a property that's
been in the family that you have a heart
for
yes i didn't know what you were going to
say about i thought you might have said
sell it or so i just wanted to talk to
you i would i would step on your heart a
little bit with my muddy boots if it was
a 10 or a 12-year
timeline but i think you can do this in
three years i think 50 000 a year out of
a 200 000 budget this is reachable
yeah oh no absolutely well and the thing
is you i understand the instant results
right you want to
and your wife is probably thinking that
well she doesn't have any emotional tie
to that house well no
and her husband's been up there fixing
it while she's been home with three kids
so she'll probably just get rid of it so
we can actually like make major progress
with our money like i understand where
she's coming from
from even just your call but for you
guys to slow down take a breath put
things in priority
and know yeah it may not all happen
overnight but in the next three years we
can get exactly what we want and cash
flow it
you need to quit going over there and
working on stuff even after you did this
you make 200
a year you don't need to do the repairs
you need to send somebody over there and
do the repairs
you got three little kids your wife's
giving you a real clear signal here
rachel's right
that's a good catch that's a good catch
on this so yeah that's that's how i
would push it out
and um what you need to do yeah
so again the thing is i
personal finance it's okay to take into
consideration
that some things are nostalgic some
things
are personal um you know i've had
over the years i've had people actually
call up and they were so gazelle intense
the
ladies ready to sell her two carat
diamond
uh wedding ring to get out of that and
i'm like no
no that's not what i meant by gazelle
intense
the sell intense is you quit doing
stupid stuff like going out to eat every
night going on vacation you don't sell
your wedding ring
now if it's an if it's a you know if
it's worth 10 million dollars or
something
you're the queen of england we'll talk
about it but but
i mean no that's not because you can't
get that back right totally
there's one of those you can't get that
back and so you protect that kind of
thing
that puts that segment of the dave
ramsey show in the books
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
caitlin is with us in san francisco hi
caitlin welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys doing
great how can we help
um so my brother sent me um
the total money makeover for christmas
and i read it two days
so that was fantastic wow thank you
yeah um unbeknownst to me i had
kind of already been working on some of
those um baby steps
but now i've kind of hit a couple
questions
that i might i need a little help with
okay
so um the first one's kind of minor and
you could probably just
spit it out real fast for me um when it
comes to
the envelope system when i if i have
anything left over at the end of the
month what should i do with that should
i roll it over
into um the next month should i throw it
towards that should i throw it towards
savings
yeah caitlyn if you have that extra cash
i would definitely throw it back towards
your debt
if you still have debt if you've not
saved your thousand dollar emergency
fund you can use that to help build it
up
but if you're still in debt you have
extra money in those envelopes yes take
that extra and throw it at the debt
now the only time there would be an
exception to that would be if it
is a category that you don't spend
monthly
on and then you can use your envelope
system as a little miniature savings
account
so like as an example uh i buy clothes
once every three years but
but some people the same way but very
few people buy clothing once a month
shopaholics do but most people don't buy
clothing monthly so your clothing
envelope could
bleed over from one month to the next
unless you're rachel
but uh but uh the uh you so if you don't
spend all your clothing money go ahead
and still spend it on clothing in a
different month
by keeping it in there car repair would
be another one of those
but the ones that rachel's talking about
are like groceries well yeah and most of
your envelopes are going to be those
things
your envelope system really is for the
categories you tend to overspend on
meaning you're spending it consistently
so if you're not spending it on clothes
i may not even have a clothing envelope
you could just have that in your budget
and no
but when you actually go to the main
cash out money that's usually going to
be
for things like groceries groceries is
the big one yeah
or yeah we have a horrible habit on
spending money
on eating out and that's where i'm like
okay
this is that budget needs to shrink
drastically yeah so and so if that
envelope had money left in it
i'm with rachel i throw that at the debt
yeah because you're going to refund
because
you're going to refund that the next
month and that rewards you for not
eating out so much
same way same with going to the grocery
store if that's got money left in it
but if it's an envelope and stuff that
is not a monthly occurrence necessarily
you can let it bleed over to a different
month and
obviously and we said this in total
money makeover questions uh
um can you get her back i'm sorry
caitlyn your other question was what you
have another one
yeah yes i do this is the the more major
one um
so my husband and i are both in school
he's a full-time student
i'm a part-time student and we have two
boys and because of the pandemic i'm
kind of homeschooling them
and so our paycheck has kind of taken a
hit
and we're actually really on the um
rice and beans kind of diet um so
um we don't have any car payments both
of our cars are paid off and we don't
have any student debt so
yay for us however um we
are living with my in-laws and they plan
on moving in the next two years and
about a year and a half they're planning
on retiring and they're moving and we
don't want to move with them
we actually have a plan to move out of
state to complete like cross-country
and so my big question is where do i
in my step two process where do i kind
of
put that on hold and move towards
building up my emergency fund for the
move planning for the move
it's a moving fund it's not an emergency
fund and so what i would do is budget
for the move figure out what it's going
to cost you
and then stop everything in time to save
that money
okay so my my question is right now i'm
not paying
rent because i'm voting with my in-laws
but when we move we will be paying right
so that's why i'm like
you'll be paying rent out of an income
you'll be you're not going to rent
something for more than your income will
cover
you don't need savings for rent okay
that's going to be coming out of your
income it'll be part of the budget
okay so where are you going to move and
would you go back out in the marketplace
if you move
um so we'll be moving to wisconsin
um and i i didn't quite catch the
section
and will you be going back to work oh
yeah
we don't actually have like jobs lined
up on the other end and that's why i
said it
wouldn't be more of an emergency fund
because you need jobs lined up before
you make the move you've got 18 months
yes don't move without the job my
husband well
my husband is getting his degree um he's
working on his bachelor's degree right
now and he will actually finish
the summer before we move like we plan
on moving before
right after he completes his degree okay
well that makes sense
all right so yeah make sure you're
paying cash for that but don't uh
go we're going to move and have six
months of savings set aside
because he doesn't have a job get a job
and then make the move because if
there's not a job in wisconsin then
there's a job somewhere else you might
not even be going to wisconsin
but my touch 22 dilemma is that my
my in-laws are moving i know you've got
to move out of that house
but you're not moving to wisconsin
without a job
you might be moving to a rental down the
street or you might be moving to austin
texas i don't know where you're going
where is he going to get a job
and that's a big deal i mean he's got to
really start talking about that
now let's go ahead and start planning
that out and start
start courting with some of those
companies and figuring out where you're
going to land
the idea of just moving over there and
hoping it all works out
uh that's a bad idea you you need that
lined out
and the good thing is caitlyn you have
you guys have time you have time to
prepare
exactly which is which is a blessing so
use that time and that way you don't
just fall off the cliff
yeah jay's in milwaukee wisconsin jay
you got a job for caitlyn's husband
no i'm sorry thanks for taking my call
oh he's from wisconsin that was funny
yeah
rachel just caught up it's okay three
two one
okay so how can we help you jay yeah uh
so
i i want to buy a building to expand my
business
uh and my business has paid off i have
no i have no bad debt just home debt
um i would have to take a loan
but i could borrow at a commercial rate
or should i borrow against a home that i
have paid off
at a lower rate what kind of business
have you got
health care okay how long have you had
it
five years how fast you're growing
on netting like i'm growing pretty fast
how many people are you adding a year
uh it's not that type of business really
um but i
but i'm as far as treating patients um
you know this is a whole completely
underserved area
okay so are your building needs growing
as fast as your business is growing
well i'm renting right where i'm at no
no i said you're building needs
as you if your business doubles do you
need double a building
uh no i don't need much space
i don't need much space so you can
double your revenues and your profits
without doubling your space
true that's what i'm asking because i
can't
well i mean i i i kind of feel like in
my portfolio i'd like to have a building
that wasn't what i asked okay i'm going
somewhere with this okay
because i i've i have made this mistake
personally and i've witnessed a lot of
small businesses that we coach may
make the same mistake so here's the
mistake
we love real estate we want a piece of
real estate in our portfolio
dude i love real estate i own several
hundred million dollars worth i
love it i mean it's my second it's my
second favorite business right
aside from ramsey solutions and so first
thing i did was i leased a building and
then i
filled it up and i had the opportunity
to buy it and then i filled it up
with people and pretty soon the mistake
i made was i was trying to make my
business
fit my building and that's damaging to
your business
because you have well i got this
building i can't just i can't yeah you
can
and so we moved out of a building i
owned and became a renter to not
constrict and choke the business and
that's what i don't want you to do here
so this i i would wait and pay cash for
the building and i would
give it a little bit more time for your
business to have a little slower growth
curve
because you're going to move in and
double your need and then you're going
to have a problem
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money it is a free call
and uh of course what we all what say it
again
[Music]
taylor and kaylee are on the debt free
stage
right here in the lobby of ramsey
solutions welcome guys where do you all
live hi
we're from texas we're from the dallas
area awesome welcome to nashville
and all the way up here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
we paid off 43 000 in two years good for
you
well done and your range of income
during that time
we uh made about 65 000 beginning the
debt free screen and now we're at 85
000.
good good we both work in ministry and
non-profits really cool what ministry
are you in
so she works at our church i'm the
connection minister there
and i work as a radio broadcaster
actually at a non-profit radio station
oh great
which station uh we are in dallas um so
i i work at a christian radio station
there that's about all i can say since
you're in the dallas market too oh
you're not allowed to say it okay
yeah just just out of com com
competition i don't mind but anyway yeah
yeah we're on a cbs over there yeah the
krld and i i've been
i've worked with salem folks down there
a bunch so i know a bunch of them if
you're in that building but i used to
work there as well yeah okay very cool
cool and which uh which church are you
in uh we were i work at my church first
taxi in uh
saxxy texas okay great very cool what
kind of debt was your 43
oh everything it was a little bit of
everything we had a
best buy credit card that i used to buy
a fridge with a tv because that's what
you need with a new home
bridge with a tv i told him no but i let
him do it
go home the door hit me on the way out i
didn't even see that i've never seen one
of those i mean it has a screen you
touch it
it's useless yeah you just you we need
pinterest in the kitchen apparently
um so we had a we had two cars that
totaled about twenty one thousand we had
a
bathroom remodel for about eleven and
then i had a eight thousand dollar
student loan so that's what made up that
forty three thousand
so y'all been married about five years
about five years uh this coming march
yeah you kind of had all the symptoms we
totally did
that's awesome so what happened what two
years ago
that you were like okay we're gonna
clean this up get moving
well we saw so i saw dave on youtube and
it really sparked an interest of what is
this guy teaching i see all these
stories and so
my wife bought me the total money
makeover about for christmas about three
years ago
let it sit on the bookshelf for a while
didn't read it for a while
but this was a book that i could not put
down and i read it in an
like front to cover in a few days and
i'm not a reader so
like this this was odd behavior for me
and
pretty soon after that it really isn't a
non-reader's book it's a not it's
it's such a fast book for a non-reader
like that's that's about the best
company i can get because i'm a
non-writer right
an on writer wrote so that's perfect
yeah well that's perfect
and so uh pretty much i just got sick of
i had that i've had it moment we i had
to have
side gigs just to pay basic bills for
our house we just got into our house and
we
uh shouldn't have gotten to the house no
but now we now we're actually in
in the range that we should have for a
mortgage payment so you know
the the debt was preventing us from
being able to live the life that we
could have
it's amazing amazing you guys so kaylee
you're more the natural saver i can tell
yes and probably are you also the the
the detail person
i'm not actually not the detailer no
taylor is the i guess the nerd it would
be he likes to do all that you guys are
like me and sharon then he's the
spending nerd
yes i'm the spending nerd but actually
since we've been out of debt it's given
me a little bit more freedom to feel
like i can actually spend money on stuff
yeah
that's been a good thing yeah you can
tell there's room and it doesn't feel
like we're doing something wrong yeah
exactly
absolutely yeah that's good way to go
you guys thank you
so the total money makeover did it well
that and what did you guys do
was it okay we're gonna budget we're
gonna because i mean you're newlyweds
right
you guys have been married three years
at that point so did you say okay we're
gonna buckle down on our lifestyle did
you work extra what did you do to
actually pay it off
yeah i had about some i i had a lot of
side gigs i do podcasting on this side
so i i produce stuff sometimes i co-host
some stuff and so
that really helped spark that uh because
i think originally it was gonna take
three and a half years
and all that sparked it to knock a year
off of it and uh
anytime we had any kind of extra we
would put it towards debt
um a lot of you know not getting it to
go out and do
fun stuff which was really hard for a
while for me and
for both of us depending on the day yeah
we really had to be strong for each
other and remind each other
why we were doing this and also
remembering that it was us who got us in
the situation
nobody else we had to fix it who were
your biggest cheerleaders
i would have to say our best friends
they're actually coming to nashville
here in a few hours
celebrate together yeah kyle and alex
hood were our biggest cheerleaders and
uh we're going to be there for
their debt-free scream in probably about
four years that's when they're set to
get out of there so
all right biggest cheerleaders for us
for sure that's fun so you just
connected up with them and all of you
are doing it from the book
yeah well we've been friends with them
for a while and we've kind of been both
going through the journey at different
areas and levels and so we've just been
encouraging each other in it so that's
really helpful and great because you
don't find a lot of people who are
trying to do this or you know
not being or they want to be normal yeah
yeah there's more people who want to
drag you down than lift you up on this
absolutely
that's for sure because they just don't
understand well yeah
yeah very cool very cool well
congratulations you guys thank you
you got no payments how's it feel oh
it's amazing
i i tell you we just reviewed our
finances
in 2020 and even for one we paid it off
on july the fourth so we celebrated two
independences yeah independence from
debt and so
yeah honestly we we reviewed our
payments in our giving and we gave more
than we ever
have in our lives and 2021's looking
way north of that and we're both in
school again as well he's getting his
masters and i'm going to finish my
bachelor's
uh for counseling and going to masters
so that that was delaying us our debt
from going to school and
kind of doing what god had called us
both too and so that's a really cool
thing as well
yeah what are you getting your master's
in uh i would love to get in my masters
in apologetics but i i really
want to do an independent study on
wealth and generosity
where that uh what that says in the
bible you know because the biggest
i think the biggest thing for me is
deuteronomy 8 reminds us that god even
gives us the power
and the ability to build wealth so when
i know from the start that my very
ability to make money
is god's it gives me a whole new
perspective yeah
you know it's exactly right and and it's
it's actually uh
uh it's a spirit of the discipline
almost it's something you're called to
do you're supposed to go do it
absolutely not just like an option no
but yeah it's very interesting and a
good friend of mine there in dallas
is probably one of the best voices on
generosity in the world you need to
connect up with him as robert morris
yes that's great church gateway church
is possibly the most generous church in
the world
yeah their their budget is absolutely
outrageous
because robert pastor robert has taught
on generosity so well for so many years
and the people's giving is just he's
become a really good friend over the
years i love the guy
and so we love gateway they've done a
bunch of stuff for us and we've done a
bunch of stuff for them but yeah
yeah you're right in the backyard of
that if you're going to do that that's
awesome good for you guys thank you it's
awesome
so proud of you so proud to a couple
listening and because there's a lot of
young people specifically on youtube and
podcasts right now and they're thinking
okay
we have fifty thousand dollars of debt
uh i don't know i don't know if it's
possible what would you say to them
i would say you know be there for each
other to be strong whenever the other
one's having a hard time because there
were several times where it'd be like oh
i want to go eat out but we have food at
home or i want to go do this thing that
everybody else is doing
uh so be strong for each other and
remember that uh
being that strict with your budget
doesn't have to last forever
so just remembering that there is an end
to it yeah that's not good i would say
that
the biggest lesson for me is god's
design is for generosity so if debt is
preventing you from giving
we are not living the full lives that
god has called us to so
just remembering that that you know
you're doing something noble here
and we both work in ministry this can be
done by anybody
yeah awesome well done you guys very
well done well stated too
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires
and that needs to be the next chapter in
your story as you continue to prosper
and continue to be
outrageously generous and we want both
for you well done
all right guys it is taylor and kaylee
from dallas texas 43 000
paid off in two years making 65 to 85.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
a sharp couple it's awesome man so
articulate so game on
well done but i love that they're caught
i mean to get out of debt you have to
have a big why
and whether that's changing your family
tree for your kids
what whatever it is and a big why of
saying i want to do what god's called me
to do i'm put on a planet to do a
purpose and i want money to be the tool
to do that
yep bob guest says the definition of
prosperity is having the money to do
god's will in your life
oh that's a little bit of money and
you're a missionary in africa or whether
it's a lot of money
and you're in a huge ministry it's
awesome what is the what is the
definition of prosperity having the
money to do god's will in your life
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two the wall street journal listed her
new book know yourself know your money
is number two on the best seller list
this week
so congratulations for that that's a
great new book discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it
all the money tendencies the money fears
and the money classroom the way you grew
up affect
your behavior and she discusses every
bit of it and if you can get a handle on
that
not because you're good or bad but
because you can then dial in and say wow
here's my
tendency here's the direction i'm going
no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency but teaching your teens
how to be smart with money can be
a big job teaching your teens anything's
a big job
we got your back with our digital
self-study courses you can be confident
your teen
will know the right way to handle money
no matter what curve balls life throws
them down the road best part no
instructor is needed
if your teen has a tablet or a computer
they're all set parents your kids can go
through our materials
there you go ramsay education dave
ramsey.com
slash self study to learn more about all
the different courses that we have
available for
middle school or high school
daveramsey.com self
study and with these kids popping in and
out of school
it's good to have something to plug them
into because some of them don't plug
into their school lessons
when they're at home like they should i
hear it's hard
we have a kindergartener and they had to
be home for a little bit and they had to
click sit in front of the computer at
five
but everyone knows it i mean yeah i mean
it's just hard it's hard
so i mean but that you're talking about
teenagers yeah i mean
you can you can make a five-year-old do
stuff making a 15 year old do
something's a different thing
all right sullivan is with us seven's in
tampa florida hi sullivan how are you
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
hey me and my wife we got a situation we
started doing about two months and um
we started two months ago we bring in
about 140 a year
uh together but she's getting ready to
to stop working she brings home about
30 to 40 a year she's gonna stop working
we bought a house about 11 10 11 months
ago
and we can sell it now for a profit of
about 65 000.
what we were thinking of doing is
because we're on baby step two
now that she's not gonna be working i
have a company vehicle
we owe 23 on the truck we want to
uh sell that for about 25 is what it's
worth
we only owe 35 3500 on credit cards
so we want to take that 62 000 and buy
and get into a smaller house payment
because right now we're paying about 2
000
a month for a 30-year mortgage how much
of the 140 were you making
a hundred thousand anywhere from a
hundred to a hundred and ten thousand
well you can pay a ten thousand dollar
payment on that
yeah yeah i get it it's just i'm trying
to put ourselves in a little bit better
situation
i'm really trying to i want to pay off
the house in five five years like
like my best friend did he did it with
you and he paid it off in five years
what's your wife saying about all this
she's okay with it she she actually got
real on board with dave ramsey i mean
we love the house i mean but it's it's
three thousand square feet and it's only
me
my wife two dogs and our seven month old
baby
it's just too much work
okay i don't i mean you don't have to
keep it if both of you want to sell it
and it accomplishes all your goals
that's fine
uh but you know the thing that's always
proposed here on the show is do i do
do i need to sell it to be in the smart
column and i don't think that's the case
here
um i think you i think you could keep it
and be in the smart column you're not
dumb for keeping it
if you love it but apparently it's not
that big a deal to you you don't care
that much about it either one of you and
you'd rather both of you would rather
have the quick financial progress it
sounds like
yeah we'd rather we want to build
traction because right now
with everything going on it's hard to
build that traction
because if we if we sell it and i i ran
the numbers right now i spend about 4
500 a month on expenses
if we sell it i've dropped my expenses
to about 2700
and with my income i know i can pay that
house off quick
then in two years she comes back to work
and she's going to almost double her
income to about 80 000
then in a few years we can decide what
we want to do moving forward
okay it there's nothing wrong with the
idea
i just wanted to make sure you didn't
feel like you had to do that
had to make that sacrifice in order for
this to work
no i just like i said now with the baby
me and her
we're all about building that well for
the baby it's not about what we want
anymore it's about
what's best for her and moving forward
as a family together
yeah well yeah and i mean you've
said this dave already but just to
reiterate you know you don't have to
sell it we never say people yeah you
have to sell your house in order to get
out of debt
it's more about your lifestyle and all
that but if you both together say hey
we don't want this we we're good living
in a smaller home we're good kind of
minimizing our life
and this gets us really far financially
then do it i mean i
we talked to a couple there's a couple
on my show and they sold their house and
moved into an apartment
just because they were so sick of the
debt they're like i just want to get rid
of everything
start over kind of breathe so if that's
what you guys want to do yeah i mean
it's a little bit of a minimalist move
yeah you know and if that's what y'all
want
it's great it's fine we're not we're not
gonna criticize you for moving down to
get traction
yeah no but but i also don't want people
to feel like
uh you have to that's the answer to
every question right uh every time you
really
have that you guys are enthused about it
and so you need to be enthused about it
because you're gonna
you're gonna sacrifice and that that's
what's going on it's awesome open phones
at triple eight eight two five 825-5225
phyllis is with us in phoenix arizona hi
phyllis how are you
i'm doing fine days this is a pleasure
for me to be able to
talk to you i've admired listening to
you for years
thank you and uh good morning rachel
hi fellas thanks for watching yes i
i'm an 80 year old woman and um i was in
an accident back in 2019
and uh i it took over a year
for the settlement to come in and i'm
just living on
social security right now and i have
these funds
it's a very big worry for me it's been a
savings right now that doesn't throw
any interest and um i have talked to
one of the banks and i'm going to go
down
tomorrow in my gut feeling i still am
so apprehensive on getting into
something
and they have recommended that i go into
a mutual fund that's going to give me
more income a month and uh it sounds
good to me so i'm not tapping into this
money
which i've had to do because how much
how much of a settlement did you get i
got
350 thousand okay and
uh i've used i bought a car because my
car was demolished
in the accident
it was and i've recovered i
had damage to my left hand and broken
ribs
that type of thing but i'm doing fine
right now
and uh well phyllis here's what i want
you to do okay
um i'm gonna put you on hold and zach's
gonna pick up and he's gonna walk you
through how to get online
and make sure that you can connect with
one of our smartvestor pros
what i'm concerned about is is that you
use the phrase i'm feeling apprehensive
and you should never invest in something
if you feel apprehensive
doing anything new has a little bit of
stress to it
but you need to learn enough about the
investment whether it's a mutual fund
which i'm fine with you investing in
mutual funds that's fine i don't have a
problem with that at all
but i want you to learn more about it so
that you're not apprehensive
because if you do something because
rachel cruz or dave ramsey said to do it
or you do something because the guy at
the bank said to do it
and then the stock market gets a little
crazy you're going to be
climbing the walls because a little bit
of apprehension is going to become
a really big pile of stress and i don't
want that for you
you need peace and peace comes from
going slow enough
that you learn enough that you're
comfortable with the investment not
apprehensive
very important so zach will pick up and
he'll help you get dialed in
with one of the smart vester pros or
help walk you through how to do that so
that
we can have you sit down with one of
them you can say okay to sit down with
your banker too
but then sit down with one of them and
then you just choose who you have
who has the best feeling yeah and do go
with your feelings that's important
you have two yeah to have different
people give you advice don't just stick
with one person and get a sense about it
yes
where you're not trying to be impressed
by them you're trying to understand what
you're doing
that's the big deal here i'm so sorry
you went through that horrible wreck and
i'm
glad you got a great settlement out of
it this is the dave ramsey chat
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five rachel cruz ramsey
personality best-selling author four
times over is my co-host today
because we're announcing today the wall
street journal lists her brand new book
know yourself know your money is number
two in the nation
so very well done good stuff all right
let's start off this hour with brooke
in spokane washington hi brooke how are
you
hey doing great thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um i was looking for some help to try to
decide whether it's smart for me to
reduce the amount i work
i work as a school teacher and i
currently work full-time
and i'd like to bring that down and
still be on track for retirement and
kind of yeah
how much do you make now brooke i make
uh
75 and you can live on less than that
obviously i do yeah i i spend
quite a lot of money i mean i don't
spend excuse me
i uh pay off my house at quite a quick
rate i'm um
i i actually the house i just purchased
i also rent out part of it as well so i
guess i should include that in my income
as well
um so i i guess i make um both that's 75
000
and i make um in terms of monthly from
rent about 2 000
a month so what is your goal here
um well really like my dream is to work
at like 60
of what i work right now and i'm 43 so
i've got another
many years of working another 20 years
of working
um and then i play music you know on the
side so i
um you know not right now because of
covid but um
that's kind of my dream is to work less
at school
and play more at night basically so you
you just want to back down your hours
now
to play and play music correct
and you can afford to do that i think so
well yeah in terms of like right now and
uh i spend um about 2 000 a month
um on my expenses and then all the rest
of my money
and all that other stuff yeah i mean it
sounds like you got tons of room in your
budget
so what's your concern um
i guess i'm just worried that if i
back down that i won't be paying off
things as quickly
and when i get to the retirement age
which is quite a long way for me
away i will not have saved enough money
basically um if you'll save 15
of your income between now and
retirement while you're paying down on
the house
you'll retire with dignity if you're
putting it in good mutual funds
uh across four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international in
roth iras and 403 b at your school or
whatever
if you got a roth there that's a good
thing if you get a match there that's a
better thing
if you're doing all of that at 15 of
your income even if with a slowed down
income you're going to be just fine
as far as having enough for retirement
you're 43
i would say you're tracking to have the
house paid off in under 20 years even if
you slow down aren't you
yeah with what i was taking what i'm
paying right now it's like
seven years yeah but you're not going to
stay on that track you were going to
slow down right
right for sure and i guess slow down
what is it 14 years maybe
yeah probably yeah so you're 57 and your
house is paid for
yeah okay it'll be okay okay
yeah well that that's what i needed was
waylaying my
apprehension yeah i mean it's just the
the thing is you you're
it's what is going to give you the least
apprehension
uh a little slower work on the thing um
but the uh um you know that i mean
you're gonna slow down a little bit or
what uh
uh are you gonna you're gonna feel
better about doing that or you're gonna
feel better by getting the house paid
off
and you know it's okay either way
nothing you're talking about here is
wrong
agreed yeah and i just think it's it's a
little bit of a different mindset
because i feel like we live in a world
where
hustle is glorified like the more i work
the more i work the more money i make
the more money i make right like that's
like that's the american mindset and
people feel that and so i could kind of
hear in his voice
it feels weird saying hey i'm going to
back off work at 43 and not work as much
so i can kind of do this hobby that i
enjoy and i love and this is my passion
that feel it it's kind of it goes
against a lot of the
cultural norms of what you hear yeah in
america today so there's fair
it's just kind of a different way the
whole song grind idea you're not doing
which is yes because there's that side
and then even like the fire
mentality is in my head the financial
independence retire early
it's not all that's bad i think there's
elements of it i would i have questions
for people that are on that track but
like
it's a little bit of that hey i'm going
to work hard and
do smart with my money early so that
when we teach people to live like no one
else so later you can listen
yeah i mean you're in baby steps four
five and six
and just slowing down the pace of that a
little bit
uh to have a greater enjoyment of your
time there's no there's not a problem
with that yeah
uh you're still gonna retire with
dignity you'll still have plenty of
money and yourself the house paid off
now if you were going to retire broke
because you did that or you were going
to retire with a house mortgage
because you did that then i would say no
i think you've downloaded back too much
yeah
i would encourage you know and you can
always turn the hours
back up if you want and and that's how
it goes
so that's the direction good question
thank you for joining us
that reminds me we always talk about
baby steps one two and three one is a
thousand dollars two is debt snowball
payoff everything but the house with
great intensity
smallest to largest three is finish your
emergency fund
when you're in those three you're on
fire you're going crazy
i mean you're completely focused you're
gazelle intense like a gazelle running
from the cheetah trying to stay alive
you are running once you break through
and you've got your
fully funded emergency fund and you
don't have any debt but the house
you go from intense to intentional
and four is fifteen percent of your
income into retirement five is
kids college and six is pay off the
house early you're doing those three
simultaneously
and you're doing them more of a marathon
pace than a sprint pace
it's intentional but you get to do some
other things and that's really what the
discussion with him was about
that's right yes we're just going to
slow that down just a little bit
i'm going to turn the work back dial the
work back a little bit
and enjoy the rhythm of life a little
bit and you never know
you know you don't get to play in some
music it might turn into some serious
money there too
sometimes when you don't have to make
money with music is when it best works
i've seen that a time or two around the
music city here
that's it so um oh man
way to go guys way to go that's good
stuff yeah go
you know when you're in baby steps one
two and three you're not eating out
you're not going on vacation it's
intensity you're running like your hair
is on fire
you know you're busting it busting it
busting it busting it busting it
but when you've got an emergency fund
and no debt except the house and a
pandemic hits you're in a lot better
place
and it's worth the sacrifice to get
there then when you get there
you get in a rhythm and so it's almost
like doing uh
like interval training or something when
you're when you're training for a long
race you can do some sprints
and some slow runs some splints sprints
and some slow runs
and that's really what you do you're
sprinting in the first three doing slow
runs in the other
that's simple good question thank you
for joining us
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out
at chministries.org
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show rachel cruz
ramsey personality is my co-host
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five we're working on a special
new podcast
and we're looking for stories from you
and
if you have a horror story about using
online
tax software we want to hear it
maybe you thought you were saving money
using software to sell file but didn't
realize they were hidden fees
or you owed a lot more than you thought
you were going to owe after you use it
or they signed you up for one of their
credit cards or their loans to cover
your tax bill
or they hounded you and spammed you and
spammed you and spammed you after using
their online tax which is actually
what they do with a lot of it so any of
this stuff if we want to hear from you
we're hearing some
real problems in that space and we
wanted some stories about it we want to
hear your stories of how you were
surprised
when doing your taxes online and we want
to fight back at these companies
that are trying to screw people over so
email us
at dave on air at ramseysolutions.com
put tax story in the subject line
and put a little bit about your story
and our gang will get with you and
collect your story and make it part of
this new
podcast we're putting together we're
going to start
going behind the scenes on some of these
industries and stepping on them
some of them are screwing you people
over and we don't
think that's okay so let's hear from you
a horror story about online tax software
send it to dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com
put tax story in the subject line please
open phones at 825-5225
is with us in orlando florida hey carla
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
all right so i started the baby steps
last january
and i got all the way through baby steps
one two and three as of right now
awesome now i don't know where to go um
i
own a business and so i have 296
thousand dollars in business debt
do i gazelle intense the business debt
or do i continue four five and six and
just
pay the business debt as it's due my
lord you got an sba loan
um i've got a business one from where i
bought the business i have a warehouse
loan from where i built a warehouse and
have a
car loan so if i stay
on track right now i can have them all
paid off in six years okay
the uh they are tech they are business
debt in your mind but they're all
technically personal that you signed for
every one of them
exactly yes and so these are personal
debts uh the car
the car loan goes down in your baby step
two
okay the real estate loan goes in your
baby step six okay
you can put the business debt wherever
you want how much of it's a business
debt
um the business loan where i purchase
the business is 133 000.
okay and what are you netting on the
business a year
[Music]
about 60. okay
here's what i would do on that is this
your only income
well last year was rough and i was
gazelle and 10. so i did this
and i did uber each and then in the
evening so
i mean in a normal world this business
is your only income and are you a single
income
yes i am okay all right so here's what
we tell small business people in entre
leadership
we we work the business debt a little
differently
inside the business itself and i'm going
to address the 130 000
we're going to put the warehouse up with
your house and baby step six you got
that
okay we're gonna put the car down in
baby step two it's your car loan
okay okay you got that now so the
business debt
we're gonna put that on the books over
here in the business
and what we tell folks there is take a
living wage
out of the business what does it take
you to live
and not not beans and rice but just have
a decent
income uh it doesn't it sounds like
that's maybe 60 000
well i'm i've only been taking like a
living wage for about 30 and then
keeping the rest
in the business to make extra payments
okay all right
so what i tell folks to do is take a
living wage out
and then whatever is left over we're
going to call that profit
and so let's say we took 40 out as a
living wage and we leave 20 in the
business as a profit okay
okay as an example for my formula now
then what i want you to do is i want you
to take some percentage of that profit
most of it and put it towards the debt
okay and i want you to put some the
other percentage in retained earnings
inside the business savings inside the
business to keep the business operating
right because businesses don't need to
run with no cash
like you can run with no cash at home
but you don't need to do that you got a
single income
this business is your k it's your it's
your saving grace it doesn't make money
you're screwed you're doing over
uber eats so we we want you making money
in the business
so i i would set your living wage about
40 because now you got to pay this car
off right and then whatever your profit
is above that
apply a percentage to it something like
80
of that profit goes to the debt and 20
goes into retained earnings business
savings okay
okay so we can build up a little cushion
inside the business itself
and pound on that hundred and thirty
thousand uh
and then as of course as you make more
and more profit your living wage is
going to stay fixed and
more and more money is going to apply to
that 80 20 rule
right right or whatever my concern was i
could get everything paid off in six
years but then i'm going to turn around
and be 50 years old
with only the retirement that i have now
and i paid for house and a paid for
warehouse and i paid for business
right yeah that wouldn't be too bad but
uh
you may still get there anyway but you
may just get there a little different
a little different way because we're
gonna knock the car out and we're gonna
knock the business out inside the
business with the formula we just talked
about
and then when you get money you're gonna
throw it over on baby step six you're
probably gonna pay your house off before
the warehouse then you're gonna pay off
the warehouse
okay and so you're gonna get there
eventually but it may be seven years it
may
i don't know you know if your business
blows up it could be five years
yeah i'm a saver so it's hard for me i
want to say gazelle the whole time but
i don't know if that's feasible no no
it's probably not you need to
you need to get in the marathon rhythm
rather than the other
so good question bill's with us in boise
idaho
hey bill your question for rachel and me
hey dave hey rachel how are you guys
good how can we help
well i had a question regarding managing
my
kid 529 plans uh at their current ages
their current one of them is in college
the other one is a senior in high school
so be in college in the fall and uh
i i currently have both of their plans
invested
in very aggressively which i
i i know i probably need to scale back
but i just wondered
um how far back you would scale that and
then
any additional money i contribute to
those plans
um would i put that in the same
uh category would i continue to even put
it in that plan to
take advantage of the tax savings or how
would you approach it
well there's not any tax savings except
on the growth and it's not going to be
in there long enough to grow so
any money i would stop funding the plan
any money you've got
for college i'm just going to pay for
college with and then i'm going to pay
for the rest of the college out of the
plan
what do you mean by aggressive
uh within the plan the options i have
it's a
idaho 529 plan so it's an aggressive
growth portfolio i think is what's
called
there's probably 80 stocks 20 bonds i
would guess
yeah a plan like that what a plan like
that calls aggressive we call
a normal good plan okay
and i think i misstated the tax savings
what i meant by that was
in idaho when i contribute to that plan
i it's a write-off on my taxes
oh your idaho income tax yes oh well you
may want to run it through the plan then
okay yeah um but you're you would be
fine leaving it in that
what they consider aggressive growth and
then can discontinue okay
yeah i think when you look inside of
that you're probably going to see funds
that look a lot like the four types we
talk about growth growth and income
aggressive growth
and international uh our kids plans
stayed in that the whole time they were
in school
outstanding i really appreciate it dave
hey thank you for the call brother
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five there we go that's it there's
another segment
i don't think you said a word i'm
listening i'm learning business debts
it's all great it's all great this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five eric and beth are
with us in hartford connecticut it says
on my screen you guys are debt
free congratulations thank you thank you
cool how much of you guys paid off 90
924 dollars way to go how long did this
take
18 months good and your range of income
during that time
169 to 184 thousand dollars
whoa what do you guys do for a living
uh i'm a lawyer and i'm in healthcare
management
good for you amazing great careers what
kind of debt was the 91 000
credit cards cars and student loans ah
so what happened 18 months ago they got
you on fire
well 18 months ago we were we were just
dating at the time
i was following this coupon lady online
and she mentioned something about
cash envelopes and dave ramsey so i got
interested and did some more research
and found you bought the total money
makeover
and got really excited about it so i
told eric about it
um and he thought the idea was great he
read your book as well
um so then we started doing our separate
debt free journeys
and during baby step two eric uh
cash flowed my engagement ring all right
um we
we opened a uh joint bank account for
our big wedding that we were going to
have
um and our nice honeymoon in hawaii to
cash flow that
but then covet happened that uh canceled
both
um so we had a very small wedding um
and realized that all the money that we
had saved up for the wedding
would be enough to pay off our debt and
we started our life
uh as a married couple debt-free wow
well that's the good end of the story
yeah except for the lack of hawaii part
yeah we're still talking about that we
hope to get there this year
for sure for sure oh wow you guys that's
incredible
okay so what would you say was the
hardest part i mean i guess you were
saving for a wedding it's kind of a
different story
um but yeah what was what was hard about
it
i think it was just the initial decision
to jump in head first
and then convince my 14 year old
daughter to do the same
that was probably the hardest how was
she
she was really really good about it
actually you know we sat down and
explained to her why we were doing it
you know and she was all in as well
yeah that's great it wasn't that bad
once we started it she didn't like the
no going out to eat or
you know the no dunkin donuts or fast
food but she she was a great sport and
now we get to enjoy that stuff that's
awesome well it is it ends up being a
family affair right when you decide to
do something it changes your lifestyle
but not just yours the kids so we hear
that from a lot of people of having to
have that conversation
with their kids that hey life's going to
look a little different for a short
period of time
yeah and you know she's getting ready to
work now and she
you know asked us the other night if we
would show her how to budget so
a lot of good that's great yeah very
good so what do you tell people the key
is to getting out of debt now that
you've done
it i think having an accountability
partner you know help that we were both
doing you know the journey
at the same time um and
you know saying saying having to say no
to things and being okay
with it yeah that instant gratification
is just something that needs to go away
will you ever go back in debt no no
you're done done i love it very
very very good good for you guys what a
fun way to start off your life right
yeah
you're not married there's no payments
oh there's such freedom in that it's a
horrible thing to
have to lose your wonderful big
beautiful wedding but it's a beautiful
thing that
ended up the way it did yeah the silver
lining
yeah if we could go back and do it over
i wouldn't change
any of it we still had a beautiful
wedding it was just very small
yeah absolutely well done you guys very
very proud of you congratulations
and uh so we've got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires that is the next
chapter in your
life for sure after debt-free now you
move on bill wealth and become
outrageously generous
so and you're in a great income position
to do that with no payments
so very very very well done all right
what's your 14 year old daughter's name
she's 16 now oh her name is mckenzie
mckenzie
eric and beth in hartford connecticut 91
000
paid off in 18 months making 169 to 184
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
excellent job well done well done well
done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
five eugene is in canada hi eugene how
are you
good thanks uh dave and rachel thanks
for taking my call guys appreciate it
sure what's up um so i'll make this
quick
uh my wife and i have a second property
that
we are currently renting out and
basically the situation is
is the amount that we take and per
monthly rent
uh we are losing about 300 a month uh
shortfall on it
so what we're trying to figure out is if
we should sell the property but if we do
um based on the closing costs and
everything else we would take anywhere
between a 10 to
15 000 hit on it um or if we should just
wait it out and you know kind of see
what seeing what happens at that point
well this piece of real estate is not a
blessing no matter what you do
yeah if you keep it it loses four
thousand dollars a year and if you sell
it you lose 10.
yeah so it sounds like about two year
break even two and a half year break
even right
correct i'm selling it
selling it okay and should i just use it
up for my
savings account or yeah yeah okay
you got the money to write the check for
the difference right yep
yeah so how did you end up in a rental
property that you owe too much on
um well before my wife and i met she
lived in this condo oh
and we we got married and then we still
had that place didn't know what to do
with it so that's why we went
out okay all right cool very good
wonderful wonderful wonderful all right
fun yeah that's uh
that's exactly what i would do i'd get
rid of it excellent stuff
yeah that's uh um it's it was not really
a rental property it was a uh
became a rental property but it was an
expense yeah yeah yeah
right and so it's just something to get
rid of it's just a problem
there's no blessing anywhere in it it's
just a matter of you know the other
thing you'll find
is that you know you know you're you're
kind of
paying some of your losses in advance by
paying eight or ten thousand dollars to
get rid of a four thousand dollar year
loss
but what you're going to get back is all
the time and worry
and anxiety and crap you've got all over
this
i was going to say the amount of head
space even just for a rental that works
and you actually make money there's
still that level of head space so to
have that
with with the rental not working and
losing money all of it oh yeah it's like
just
just get rid of it yeah that makes a lot
of sense
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five uh hannah is on twitter we
need your help my husband and i have
been saving for a down payment on a
house instead we took that money
decided to make a large part of our
savings and pay down our debt
we paid off everything but one student
loan twenty three thousand do we start
saving again for the down payment on the
house or pay the student loan off
instead
pay the student loan off before you buy
and then get that emergency fund in
place
hannah and then you start saving for
that down payment because
and i get we get this a lot there's a
lot of people they they're itching to
buy a home
because when you buy a home you feel
settled it feels like a good investment
it's the american dream it's just what
you do
but when you do that when you have no
money when you have debt when you don't
have savings
it just creates this mess and it does we
say it all the time here but it's true
it ends up being
such a curse rather than a blessing and
homes are expensive one of the easiest
cheapest days it feels like of owning a
home is the day you
you buy it and then from there on it is
upkeep and
it's wonderful but a lot of money goes
into it so again putting
not having that stress on your life is
so worth it when you don't have money
but when you have no debt
and a savings account and a good down
payment that's when you buy
exactly exactly you clean out because
then you're going to have the house is a
blessing instead of a curse
and when you move into a house with no
money and a bunch of debt hanging around
your ears
you're asking for trouble the heat and
air is going to go out the washer
the hot water heater is going to go out
the roof is going to leak and you're
going to get yourself in a pinch
don't let that happen to you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 1 5 let the
wise hear
and increase in learning and let the one
who understands obtain
guidance john f kennedy said leadership
and learning are indispensable to each
other
darren is with us in minneapolis hi
darren welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking a call sure
what's up
well i feel like i'm kind of running out
of time to become a millionaire
but i've got i'm 48 and
i'm trying to decide if i need to take
my
savings of 260
and put that down towards the mortgage
or if i
save some of that and put it towards my
retirement right away and then have a
goal to
pay off the mortgage in like two to
three years
how much deal on your mortgage
about 220. oh so you could just pay it
off
yes what's your your household i know
what's your household income
i met about 140. then you have nothing
in retirement other than this money
about 25 000. and this money is not in
retirement
correct where'd it come from um
i had a career transition in the last
two or three years and i've just been
saving like crazy
good for you okay
okay so the good news is you have
learned how to save
yeah yeah i was going to say darren
you're not going to have a savings
problem
because you're pretty good at it
considering
how much you saved in such a short
period of time so you almost could pay
off the house
today continue that savings habit for a
little bit
build up your retirement and yeah you'll
be back there you'll be back there super
fast
uh because you've built that muscle and
you don't you know with no payments in
the world
what i would do is pay it all off i
would set aside an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
and then i would load up every possible
retirement account
you got a 401k at work
no i'm looking into getting a set
because i'm self-employed
okay you got it you got employees
uh not yet okay sepal work great until
you have employees you want to do a roth
uh you might look into the simple ira
it's a 401k for small business
in addition to that you can do a roth
ira are you single
no married okay you can do two roth iras
does she work outside the home
no i was thinking about hiring her to do
book work so we can get
uh not worth it yeah it's not worthy
that way you could do the
you can do a roth ira for her anyway you
don't have to create an earned income
for her to do that
and the taxes that you'll pay bringing
her in on payroll and everything else
won't make it make sense so don't do
that
i looked at it i almost did it several
times when i was your size
in our business uh and i just couldn't
ever get the numbers to work out
but you can do two roth iras one for her
one for you
seven thousand each at your age and and
then you can oh no i mean you're 48
no i mean when you turn 50 you can do
seven six now and uh then you can do
uh do the uh 401k um
a simple ira which is a 401k for small
business
or do the sep either one do all those
load them up and then in addition to
that you're just saving in the wild wild
west out in mutual funds
i'm probably just using a uh you know
some good growth stock uh
probably a uh s p 500 or something like
that
sit down with one of our smartvestor
pros they can help you map all of that
out
but i think when you run the numbers out
without a house payment you max out
everything in retirement and you save
over and above
that invest not just save but invest
over and above that
you're going to be right back where you
are in about 20 minutes it's going to
scare you how quick you got back to 240
and you will have had a paid for house
all that time which adds
adds to the net worth as well big time
yep big time
two major components to retiring with
dignity a nest egg and a paid for house
and we found those in every virtually
every millionaire we found in the
millionaire next door or not millionaire
that's the everyday millionaire study
millionaire next door of course is tom
stanley in 1992
that inspired all of us by the way but
the uh yeah that that
uh the study that we did we found the
typical millionaire with one two three
million dollar net worth
about a third of their net worth was
their paid for house about
two-thirds was their loaded up
retirement accounts
and that that you know so you got a
million and a half dollar net worth 500
000 in the house million dollars in
mutual funds and 401ks
yeah and you know that that's where
you're going to be pretty easy
and your income's great darren as well
that's going to add to that so yeah
you'll be yeah you'll be good excellent
excellent excellent
very very well done proud of you man all
right
zach is in kalamazoo michigan hi zach
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
so i wanted to know um if i made the
right decision
to go back to school so um a little bit
of background is
i'm 24 years old and i had left school
um due to some addiction issues i had
i went and handled that and my
grandfather seems to think that i'm an
idiot
and going back to school doesn't make
any sense and
it's going to cost me 40 grand to finish
my degree
and i have 105k liquid assets
and i wanted to know if i made the right
decision to come back to school
what are you studying um finance
okay what do you want to do i want to
work in a bank
and help people with their investment
accounts
and really grow and um become
financially independent
what was the nature of your addiction
so i had a cocaine issue
okay and how long you been clean two
years
way to go zach that's very powerful
that's very powerful that's a very tough
one to kick and you've been clean two
years that's a beautiful thing brother
proud of you
and it took my dad oh no
i'm so sorry yeah so your grandpa's your
grandpa's opinion means a lot then
yeah he was you know after my dad died i
got into the same drug
my dad died from man my dad
my grandpa was my dad growing up and
he means the world to me yeah so why is
he calling you an idiot
for going to school so
um because in the past i wasn't focused
on
it's more an environmental thing that
he's worried about less about the
education
exactly yeah he's worried about the
cocaine on campus
um yeah and you know no matter how many
times i tell them
that i haven't spoke to those people
since before i went and
got sober and no part of me ever wants
to go back to where i was
he like he still sees all the mistakes i
made all the
false promises and everything else yeah
and
you know he runs my trust fund because i
had won a lawsuit
um when i was younger and i'd spent
so much money like wasted so much money
and um you know and i wasted a good
amount on school
okay so let's let's clarify here for a
second then your grandpa doesn't think
you're an idiot for going
to college he thinks he's afraid that
you're going to get hooked
up with the wrong crowd again that's
what he's worried about
yeah and the way expresses himself might
be wrong might be more like me
but uh okay that's fair
so i think you talked to him about what
you could do
to grandpa in what situation i think
education is important
to do what i want to do how can i go
about getting that education
in a way that you would uh endorse
maybe a different school yeah yeah or
even small things living
off campus or you know what i mean a
living situation that's different
do you live with your grandpa uh no
i actually just moved out and
so back during my addiction i was living
off campus
and what i decided to do this time
around was
live in the on-campus apartment yeah
there you go so it's the opposite yeah
that's that's good well i think you just
talk through with him some of the things
you're doing to protect yourself
and ask him if he thinks there's
anything else you can do to protect
yourself
um he's had he's lost a lot of people to
white powder so i don't blame him for
being sarcastic and blame him for being
um worried fearful a lot of fear and so
i don't blame him for that
i don't necessarily think he's right but
i don't blame him for doing that well
and on the
on the financial side zach yeah taking
that 105
yeah and going and spending 40 and
getting your degree yes i would do that
which is great
yeah the whole trick is to do that and
navigate
the post-addiction mentality and that's
where you need to be
so i'm proud of you brother you call us
anytime we'd be honored to help you as
you do walk through this
you're a sharp young guy rachel good job
good job
thank you thanks for having me on that
puts us our dave ramsey showing the
books thanks to james childs our
producer zach bennett filling in for
kelly today i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you